foreign
[Music]
you to the presentation of the advanced
simulation tool for guest understeered
bioreactors my name is Kristen mitz I'm
from the spin-off company cementage and
we make reactor simulations accurate
fast and easy
so what is the challenge the challenge
of course is that this step that is
designed and the control of reactors is
still based on empirical knowledge
there's a lack of deeper process
understanding in these directives and
this now then leads to rudimentary
scalar procedures like constant PDF by
we constantive speed constant KLA
geometrical similarity
it doesn't really give a picture about
the complex processes which are
happening inside the director
therefore we have another approach we
use
the approach that we ask ourselves what
does the cell or the microaginism feel
when they float through the reactor and
this is called the lifeline approach
and for the lifeline approach we need to
simulate all the physical parameters
within the bire reactor and then we know
um what the cells or microorganisms feel
in terms of dissolved oxygen for example
or in terms of shear stress in terms of
nutrient concentration and so on
and now how do we get from our physical
first principle-based reactor scale up
and
using those cell lifelines with what we
have
um the geometry and the operating
conditions
the basis for all
um all the simulations all the further
simulations is the fluid and bubble
simulation
building up on the fluid and bubble
simulation with the simulation of
substrate where we know for example the
nutrient concentration
or um the
dispersed space simulation where we can
simulate oil droplets which are
dispersed in the reactor but this can
also be used for reaction starters for
example and we can also add a model to
simulate the temperature the shear rate
directly comes out of the fluid
simulation
and can be directly used for the
lifelines
and the results of all the other models
also flow into our Lifeline concept
but let's start with the fluid and
bubble simulation
for the fluid simulation we use the
lattice bosma method what is the latter
Sportsman method basis of every fluid
movement are gonna be Stokes equations
and what has been done up to now is that
we use a definite volume method finite
element method the final differencing
scheme to approximate these novel Stokes
equations and these methods are
perfectly suited for the CPU so your
main Processing Unit in your computer
but the new generation of algorithm
um converts the navistox equation into
the boltzmann equation the bartzmann
equation is equation of statistical
mechanics and then approximates
um this Bosman equation with the lattice
also method and this lets both the
method is ideally suited for gpus for
graphic cards and as the graphic cards
because of Bitcoin and Gamers
um because of the graphic cards getting
faster and faster every year
we're getting a faster and faster latest
Bossman simulation every year
and
the reason for why this is so fast is
because it's highly parallelized and
it's about 10 times faster than the
classic methods
and what is important inside the reactor
because we deal with very small cells or
microorganisms is that we model the
turbulence correctly because on the cell
level on the microorganism level we have
very fine turbulent edius and this are
simulated in the latter Sportsman
directly with the large any simulation
and all this turbulent edges with just
more than the cell size are modeled with
the so-called smarterenskis upgrade
model
and with that we already can produce
very fancy pictures of the flow field
within the reactor but the question
always is with simulation results is
that correct
and for that to compare it's best to
take a line throughout the reactor at a
certain distance to the steer axis for
example and then compare
um physical experimental PID
measurements it's particle image image
velocity where you add some particles
and then you take a extremely
um two pictures in an extremely short
time and then you see how much they how
far they move and then you know um with
the time and the distance of the
movement you know the velocity then you
can
um bring this velocity into a diagram
and compare it to our simulation that
our simulation are the green dots in
this diagram
and you see that you get a very good
agreement
and with that you can do your first use
case
these are two intermixtures
with the same turning Direction but
different sterile engines
and what is shown is a cross-section
through the reactor the darker the color
the faster the velocity and the errors
give an indication where the fluid is
flowing and if you now have the task to
bring solids from the bottom into
suspension inside the reactor you
immediately see that you would choose
the configuration on the right because
the fluid field is much more pronounced
here on the bottom
with that we can come to the power
simulation and for the power simulation
we use a two-way coupled lagrangian
model what does that mean lagrangian
means that we follow each of these
bubbles directly a two-way cupboard
means that not only pushes the fluid the
bubble around but also the power can
push the fluid around this means if you
don't have a stera in your reactor if
you have a bubble column
then you can simulate
um this um
of fluid vortices which are forming
because the bubbles take the fluid um
with them to the top and the fluid has
to come down
um at the walls of the reactor
and for the movement of the public then
you know where they are going we solve
the Newton's equations of motion this is
simply all the forces which act on such
a bubbles rubber are summed up and with
the resulting Force we know the
acceleration and the velocity and the
position at the end of each time step
and because
um in a production scale reactor the
number of Barbers is so high we grew
some of um the bubbles together which
have similar properties
and this is called the parcel approach
what the bubbles can do if they move
around is that they collide with each
other if they now collide with each
other two things can happen and to
choose what if the two things is
happening and we use the coalescence
model of Summerfield
either the two bubbles Collide and
separate again just exchanging momentum
or this little tiny film between those
Barbers when the touch ruptures and the
big bubble is formed and then a
coalescence event is taking place and to
decide
um if either the exchange momentum and
separate again or if a big Power is
formed you have to you can use the
coalescence model of Summerfield where
you can compare the contact time of
these two bubbles
um with the film drainage time how long
this film takes to rupture
and if the film drainage time is longer
then the bubbles just separate again and
if the film
rupture time is shorter
then and the contact time is longer than
a big bubble is formed
but The Barbers do not only get a larger
they also get smaller and this is called
a breakup event when the power breaks
apart and this is mainly caused by
turbulent Eddies which are in the size
range of these poppers because larger
edges just transport the bubbles around
and the smaller edits do not have enough
energy to tear the bubble apart
and with for example the model of luense
new directly get the data bubble size
distribution and this means that you can
directly calculate
um if uh equalized bubbles are formed or
if a larger and a smaller bubble is
formed after the breaker behind
and together with the breakup frequency
so how often such a breakup event occurs
with the double bubble it says
distribution and the breakup frequency
you can model that whole breakup within
your reactor
and with this you can already do first
test cases
um we have a 150 liter Plexiglas reactor
in our lab where we test the
distribution of The Barbers and the size
of the bubbles with connectivity probes
um this reactor is three rational
turbines
and we tested five different flow
regimes some without recirculations some
with rear circulation and different
recirculation
Pro regimes which are then
differentiated a better guessing rate
and this is also experimental validation
which is shown in our paper from
chemical engineering science and where
you can read that
um we have a good agreement between the
experimental values and the simulated
ones
often especially in industrial size
reactors it is important to know the
power number so how much power do you
have to use to turn this theorem
and this power number simulation can be
done in two ways
either you sum up all the forces which
act on the steerer and multiply these
forces on each different parts of the
stereo with the distance to the steer
axis then you have the torque then you
can up all the torques which act on the
steerer and get a resulting torque
and with this way you can calculate the
Power number
or you say that
um all the energy which is brought into
the into the liquid is caused by
listeria and therefore in the simulation
you can sum up all their energy
dissipation or the energy which is
present in the liquid and can then
calculate back how much power
um has the stereo transmitted
um to the liquid
and those two methods either with the
torque in blue or with the energy
dissipation gives you as you can see
here the same result
and it gives you the correct result
because we did that with a Russian
turbine and the Russian turbine has
power number of five
and this also agrees over all the flow
regime so coming from turbulent to
transitional to laminar we get
um all the correct
um
results
um comparing with the experiments from
the club so slow carnic for example
and this power number
often has a dependency on how fine the
grid is because if you go for a final
grid you have a finer forces on this era
for example where you can calculate the
energy dissipation
in a better way but in our case you see
that you have a very very low grid
dependency so you can go very low very
big cell sizes and already get a correct
Power number
and this can also be done for the guest
case and the unguessed case
um and it's even more difficult because
you have to get the gas power number
correct an unguessed power number
correct and then for example you can
compare it with experimental values of
Nino
um
and see that you have a very good
agreement from this simulation
um with the experimental values
um what is a bit um
difficult but very interesting is um
that we can also detect flooding in our
simulation
so flooding is when listeria
um cannot distribute the bubbles
radially if it's a radial steerer
radially anymore if you think about the
Russian turbine if it's flooded the
bubbles just flow around the steerer and
flow to the next zero and the Russian
turbine cannot distribute the bubbles
anymore readily because either it's
turning too slow
or the gas flow rate is too high
and
in the simulation you can see it very
easily but in for example stainless
steel reactors often is is the bottom
steerer which is flooded
in a stainless steel reactor you cannot
see this and you lose a lot of
efficiency in your reactor if the steer
is flooded
so
what we we do to detect the flooding is
that we place a virtual cylinder around
the steerer and now if the stereo
functions correctly the flow is from the
inside to the outside of this virtual
cylinder because the the stereo pushes
the fluid outwards
now if the steer is flooded like in this
picture then the bubbles go to the top
and with this circulation
and now if a fluid and the liquid flows
from the
um from the side towards the steerer
and the fluoride of this virtual
cylinder is changes the sign and this is
what you see here here the steerer is
not flooded in the higher RPM range in
the on the right of this diagram and if
you go lower with the rotational rate
then you see that at some transition
point which you can then detect
um the sign switches of this um flow
rate and then you are flooded in in this
um regime which is shown uh on the
bottom side of this diagram and this
transitional point you can now compare
um with experiments like from rumors
Kirkland and you see that the
experimental value and the simulated
values and good agreement and therefore
we can use this simulation to detect
flooding inside a reactor
so we also want to be able to simulate
very large buffers because
um especially non-Newtonian reactors
large bubbles can be present which
accumulate
um in zones where there's a low Shear
rate and the bubbles accumulate it gets
stuck accumulate together and then break
free if they have a certain size and
then you have very large puppets and
this is a still work in progress and the
good thing is that you would be able to
simulate caller sense and break up of
these bubbles if you simulate the whole
surface of the power you can simulate
coalescence and break up directly
but what we we can do
um with this free surface model is to
model the free surface of the reactor
and if you have a reactor without any
baffles then this Vortex is formed
and with the free surface model we can
simulate The Vortex and this is
especially important because when the
when these a Vortex touches the steerer
then it often comes to foaming
and of course you have to validate this
and the validation cases were done by
the prakash and where you can either
compare a picture with the simulated one
here on the left you see a very good
agreement or for the 500 RPM case he has
given a literature value of the lowest
point of this Vortex and you see that
this agrees as well
and what you can then do is um that
sometimes these um vertices are used
um to get more oxygen into the reactor
and this is called surface gassing and
for this we included the possibility to
simulate the mass transfer through the
surface into the reactor
and then you can simulate how efficient
you are aerating your reactor without
getting any forming problems
so now we've mastered the fluid and
bubble simulation we can come to the
substrate
simulation and for the substrate
simulation we need a passive scalar
transport algorithm we do it with the
one um with the method of osmanlich
where we just
um are able to um
decide how much of or
which part of the mass which is present
in one cell is transported to the next
cell by comparing the density
distribution vectors which we get out of
the fluid simulation
and with this algorithm which is not
very complicated we can already do
simulations like that this is a reactor
um without an exterior just a bubble
column the bubbles are not shown here
for visibility but what we see here is
uh already the dissolved oxygen in this
bubble column so the the oxygen is
transferred from the bubbles to the
liquid and within the liquid we use our
Mass transfer algorithm to transport
this dissolved oxygen around
and for the mass transfer from the
barber to the liquid we use the ADSL
model because this has been shown that
this ldcl model gives the best results
for a normal operation of the directors
and of course we have to validate this
as well we use here the measurements of
c and he has shown a mixing time that
when you add like for example a salt how
long does it take that you reach the 95
mixing time so that all 95 percent of
the reactor is within this certain
homogeneous concentration
or there are no not more deviations than
five percent from the uh average
um concentration and at this point can
be measured experimentally and also with
the simulation and you see here that
ideally All Points would be on the 45
degree online
um but you see that they are in very
good agreement and are pretty close to
these 45 ideally 45 degree length
but you can do the same for the KLA so
how much Austin is transferred
um from The Barbers to the liquid and
you see that here the experimental
values and the simulated values have a
slightly larger deviation but this is
still a very good result if you think
about how hard it is
um to measure the kle experimentally
correct
so the deviation in the experiments by
itself is oftentimes higher than the
deviation to our simulated values so
this is a good agreement
so the next thing we are looking at is
um introducing a dispersed phase in the
into the reactor like for example oil
droplets
and these droplets are used for
nutrition of cells and microorganisms
and these droplets are ranging from 10
to 1000 micrometers and it would be too
costly
um to simulate each or follow each oil
droplet individually and therefore we
use the population balance equation
and this population balance equation
just um
Define certain size classes for the oil
droplets for um for the explanation I
use here free size classes in green a
large amount in blue
um the one we are looking at and in
yellow a smaller one and now if you have
a control volume like this box you know
how much convection you have into this
control volume of this of these
particles of your size cars how much
convection goes out of your control
volume and within the control volume the
particles can call us to a larger to
enter the larger size class and these
particles of the larger cells scarce can
break up to enter our size cars and the
same
can be achieved for breakup to the
smaller size class and the coalescence
of the smaller particles
um to our size class if you now sum up
all these processes you know the rate of
change of your particle concentration
for your S-Class I for example and if
you do that for all the size classes you
know the size distribution of these oil
droplets within your reactor
and again you can do a validation here
with the data through Sardine
um the open symbols are the experimental
values the colored lines are our
simulations and you see a very good
agreement between
experimental and simulated values and
for another oil for cornrow oil you see
a slightly larger deviation in the
smaller droplet size but we get a
perfect agreement in the average
diameter of the droplets
but more interesting than this um graphs
are is the size distribution within the
reactor and here you see this
um rather large control volumes normally
use smaller control volumes but just um
to explain the principle
um here in the area around the steerer
as you would expect you have smaller a
smaller average diameter and below the
gas departure there's not a lot of Shear
or turbulence happening you have a
larger oil droplets
and then you can do a very nice
simulations where you start with a high
volume fraction of this burst oil in the
top and the low volume fraction of this
burst oil on the bottom and then the
bottom part of course you have a lower
viscosity and you immediately see that
if you look at the velocities that
these velocities are much more
pronounced in the lower half because the
viscosity is lower now if the the
consideration of the oil is because the
stereo is turning and mixing everything
together you can see that slowly we're
getting also a turbulent flow field and
on the top and if now all this oil is
homogeneously distributed within the
reactor you can see also that the the
flow field in the top and the bottom of
the reactor is now equal
the last one of our modules which I want
to present today is the temperature and
for the temperatures you would expect
you can define a heating jacket for
example and then see how the temperature
field evolves over time interestingly
we're using the same algorithm as for
the mass transport but now the quantity
which is transported is thermal energy
and we can do the same also for
submerged tube bundle heat exchangers
and this tip merge two panel heat
exchangers are for example used in large
scale fermentation reactor we can
simulate up to 250 cubic meters that
simulations we have already done and
these Cuban heat exchanges can also be
simulated
um if they cool down or heat up the
reactor
but the main source of heat in a
bioreactor normally
um are the the cells or microorganisms
and therefore we can introduce massless
Tracer particles mass less because the
cells and mechanisms are so small
um that they do not influence the flow
field but they are just transported
around by the flow field and then we can
switch up
um
we can assign every one of these Tracer
particles a certain quantity of heating
or a certain heating power and then we
can see how the temp the reactor heats
up because of the heating power of the
cells or micronisms if you have a
biological model you can also directly
calculate the heat generated by that
biological process and this would lead
to an even more refined simulation than
in this case where every every cell has
the same heating capacity
the last source of heating or cooling is
in this example is um that
um
The Barbers or the compressed air which
is pressed into the gas voucher can have
a different temperature than the
surrounding liquid and therefore
we can also simulate the temperature of
the bubbles and we had one case where
there was an unexplained Cooling in the
reactor
and we could explain that with the cold
air which was pressed into the reactor
and of course the cold air heats up if
the bubbles arise in the reactor but the
liquid
um cools down and then gives a heat or a
temperature gradient which was
previously unexplained but could be
explained and by assimilation
and with that we come to our cell
lifelines finally and with the cell
lifelines we use uh again dispersed
cells which we already have seen they
are massless Tracer particles and
um for uh we use a representative number
of cells because the real number of
cells in the bar reactor is just too
high for every computer that is
available today
um but with a representative number of
these dispersed cells and we can record
this life and
use this massless Tracer particles and
an example of this a Lifeline for the
shear can be shown here over time so
it's a diagram over time and if you look
at these spikes in the shear rate you
see that this is are the points in time
whereas the cells are close to the
steerer in a high Shear Zone can also
then Define thresholds
um above which the cell is marked as
that for example and you can do the same
diagrams for oxygen dissolved oxygen
dissolves CO2 substrate concentration or
the rate of product conversion if you
have a biological model
but even more interesting that than this
time series of one cell
is that we are looking at all the cells
we're asking all the cells to give us
their current for example Shear rate for
specific times
and this now leads to these histograms
where we have a Shear rate on the x-axis
this is a very low Shear rate
um here in the very high Shear rate here
and we are asking every one of these
cells to give us their Shear rate and if
one cell tells us a specific to Shear
rate and they share it in uh it gets
increased by one pin count
and now it's not that interesting and to
do this for the same reactor for
different times but it's very
interesting to do that for example for
different reactors of different sizes
or if we have a process transfer to do
it for the base reactor and the target
reactor because then we can compare the
shearates of two reactors on the basis
of what micronisms or cell feel when
they float through the reactor and this
is gives us a quantitative comparison
where we then can do scale up with that
because we can compare the shear rate
the dissolved oxygen at specific times
for example in the fermentation phase
and then we can also generate for
example scale down models where we look
at these histograms
at the large scale and then create
models of reactors which give us the
same histogram in a small scale
so to sum up
um I've presented the simulation
Technologies for all bioreactors and it
gives unique insights into reactors we
use validated algorithms based on the
first physical principles and you can
design optimize or troubleshoot your
reactor in silicone if you're interested
leave me a message at christian.whits at
teograds.a T or christian.twits at
simvantage.com
and I would be happy to get in touch
with you to discuss
um your scale up scale and process
transfer troubleshooting Challenge and
how to convert that and in the
simulation challenge thank you